did you know that you can ask guests
your questions that's right when you
join our locals community not only will
you know who we're about to interview
you have the opportunity to ask them
your questions you have the chance to
ask jordan peterson the co-founder of
extinction rebellion nigel farage
douglas murray andrew doyle jeff norco
simon evans larry elder david bedeal
andrew sullivan megan kelly julia
hartley brewer lord nigel lawson brett
weinstein inaudible
dr david nutt jimmy dore gad sad blair
white melissa chen trevor phillips
ayanne hersey ali glenn lowry bridgeford
to see jim rickards carl benjamin and so
many more plus we're about to interview
some of the biggest guests
in the world we can't name them just yet
but trust me they're huge metaphorically
speaking not just because they're
american our locals gives you access to
a great community of like-minded people
where you can share memes and make new
and problematic friends you also get
early access to live shows and we're
about to release details of our tour so
you'll want to know about that as well
on the higher tiers you get monthly
supporter calls and the opportunity to
have a meal or a call with us click the
link below or go to
trigonometry.locals.org
and join the community that's
trigonometry.locals.com
we'll see you there
i did not realize
how young the kids are when they start
them on
the actual medical transition part of it
how young are they matt
well i mean as young as uh as young as
10 11 years old when they start them on
the on the hormones and you get into
puberty blockers the surgery especially
i i
year and a half ago
i didn't realize that they were actually
that they really were mutilating kids i
thought that
you know this is something that starts
at the age of 18. but no i mean they
chop the breasts off of uh
13 and 14 year old girls even younger
sometimes
hello and welcome to trigonometry on the
road from the usa and we're recording in
the daily wire studios i'm francis
foster i'm constantine kitchen and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people
our brilliant and rather controversial
guest today is the author of what is a
woman the brilliant documentary that you
have heard about by now matt walsh
welcome to trigonometry thanks for
having me uh it's a real pleasure thank
you for making the time you're a very
busy guy we've got half an hour with you
so i'm not going to mess around we'll
get straight into why did you decide to
make the movie
well because uh gender ideology which is
what the movie is really about is uh i
think a scourge
on western civilization it's uh it's
it's
plunging you know children especially
into lives of confusion and uh identity
crisis and despair
uh you know i think everyone kind of
notices this when you look around that
it seems like everyone's lost their
minds and over the last like five or ten
years um where questions that were once
pretty simple to everybody
and you did so simply even think about
them now are confusing and um basic
concepts about you know life are now
confusing to people and so the movie is
sort of like what first of all why is
this happening
how widespread is this problem actually
and then
once we've established that to get into
exposing you know where it comes from
and everything else and when you say how
widespread it is that's one of the
interesting points that we are kind of
exploring at the moment is it seems
quite often one side is focusing on the
extremist on the other side and
presenting that as the entirety of the
other side so how wide spread did you
find that this issue was how you know
what percentage of the population think
that you can just change your sex by you
know cutting bits off yourself or
whatever it is oh it's from what i've
found it's very widespread it and that's
that's something that i was a little bit
surprised by now i knew that this was a
a
a big problem which is why we made the
movie to begin with i knew it was
pervasive but i thought you know even
because we talked to ex so-called
experts in the film we also did a lot of
man on the street interviews
um and many that didn't make it into the
films it's only an hour and a half and
we talked to i don't know dozens and
dozens and dozens of people
and what i found just going cities and
towns across the country and talking to
average people walking down the street
is that uh
a lot of these
sort of half-baked notions that i hear
from the gender studies professors and
therapists are also coming out of the
mouths of just average people walking
down the street
um in an even more half-baked way like
for them it's even more sort of
undercooked that they don't
like they've picked up these ideas they
haven't really thought much about them
um but they've picked them up is the
point and what i also found is that the
you know the the titular question of
what is a woman
was a stumper not just to
the so-called experts but also to most
average
people walking down the street how much
of you of that do you think is
fear-based because like you said we all
know the answer to this question
suddenly they get you know they're on
camera they've got a guy asking them
questions i mean
if they answer the wrong way this could
get them fired couldn't it
yeah i think that's that's that's a big
question too is is uh why especially the
average folks that are seem to be
confused are they actually confused or
are they just afraid to answer it and i
think it's a mixture of the two i think
it's a but i think it's a lot more
fear-based and and i know that actually
for a lot of them because they told us
that there are there are many more who
didn't appear in the film because they
didn't want to be on camera and they
said to us that well i can't talk about
that i'll lose my job i'll lose my
friends all you know
and they went through the whole list of
consequences
and so i i think that there's this
that's the other thing people have
picked up is that even if they haven't
been explicitly told
it's that
if you talk about this you better be
very careful because if you say the
wrong thing you know we're going to ruin
your life i remember in 2016 my cousin
went to sussex university i don't know
if you've heard of it it's but it's the
locust university in the uk infamous and
in in a lecture in 2016 or rather a
class
the f when he first got to the
university he was asked to declare his
pronouns this was in 2016.
do you think it started round about that
time or did it go back even further do
you think yeah that's the thing when
you're when you're tracing the origins
of this you kind of decide how far back
you want to go i mean you could go back
centuries if you want to want to we we
talked to someone in the film named carl
truman who's a great author wrote a book
called the rise and triumph of the
modern self and um
and which i would really recommend
everybody read upcoming guest i'm not
sure oh great and watch watch it and
everyone should watch that show and when
you come when he comes and he's a really
interesting guy
and he talks about the same question of
like how did this happen why is it that
he especially frames it as
the statement i'm a man trapped in a
woman's body
that seems to mean something to modern
people it wouldn't have meant anything
to our grandparents so how is it that
this statement means something to us and
he traces this back philosophically
hundreds of years right and so you could
do that
um you could kind of decide where you
want to start in the film we trace it
back kind of to these landmark moments
we trace it back to
uh
alfred kinsey john money mid 20th
century the sexologists and
psychotherapists
and although they didn't invent all of
the concepts they did come up with
i think
what we know of today as as gender
ideology john money in particular coined
some of these phrases
um like gender identity he coined that
phrase so
you could kind of you go back to there
and these ideas start getting into
especially the institutions like
academia and they're kind of in these
high level places but then they cut they
filter down you know slowly at first i
think into the general population and
seven or eight years ago i think that's
when it sort of exploded onto the
mainstream it didn't start there but
that was the that's when the floodgates
were open and you could go to you know
bruce jenner coming out as caitlyn
jenner winning woman of the year
um
that for a lot of people was the first
time they were really confronted with
they may have heard of transgenderism
before that but that was the first time
that it was really in their phase and um
and then from there it was just kind of
off to the races i think
and you mentioned people having their
lives ruined i hope you don't mind me
saying there's quite a lot of security
around your building here
is that necessary have you had to have
that to be able to make a movie like
that yeah i mean sadly it's necessary in
general just because of what we all do
here um and so that's a lot of the
security is not specifically for me it's
just because this is what you know this
is this is the world we live in now and
um
but
i could say for for me in particular
when the movie came out yeah we got
death threats docks to all the rest of
it
quite a lot of it you know
um
a lot of it that i haven't talked about
in really specific terms just even for
security reasons i can't even say some
of the things people have said to me and
that was all you know it that was all
expected um it shouldn't be expected but
we know that
and i'm certainly the first first person
to experience this that trans activists
are
vicious on a level that
other kinds of activists rarely reach
why do you think that is
uh i think there are
a lot of reasons for it's like some of
it goes like in a deep psychological way
um i think trans activists can be even
more vicious to to women who stand up to
them great and i think part of the
reason for that if i'm just to like
psychoanalyze them is i think that
there's some envy and jealousy actually
um
it's the male trans activists in
particular who are who are the most
vicious in my experience and i think in
the experience of women who stand up to
them
but then also it's it's
there's like this idea that
they're
if you disagree with them
[Music]
that you are interfering with their
self-perception
and
if you interfere with their
self-perception it's like a form of
murder they see because if you if you
take away how they perceive themselves
or if you interfere with that or
question it
um then you're like destabilizing
their perception of themselves do you
think they actually think this because
i've always thought of it as a
linguistic trick it's a way of
legitimizing violent behavior or threats
of violence by claiming that you know
you're raising their existence when
actually i think they realize they're
still there right well do you think they
genuinely believe that by saying you
can't change your biological sex you are
erasing them
i i think it's i think it's a mixture of
both there's a lot of drama and
pageantry that goes into and any time
the outrage brigade gets into action
there's always there's always a lot of
uh
people that are pretending to feel
things they don't really feel but but
but for some of them it's at some level
they do actually
think that the most important thing
about them is how they perceive
themselves
and um and so you know if you're a man
who identifies as a woman
then that's who you are but it's this
very fragile
thing
and um if they hear anyone question it
then they just sort of
panic and lash out sometimes violently i
think matt how do we separate the people
who genuinely have gender dysphoria
which is a horrible mental illness and
they genuinely need support and
treatment
for dealing with that illness and this
ideology how do we separate that still
having compassion for for people with
gender dysphoria but also
criticizing and challenging
the
not so elements of the ideology
well first of all when you're dealing
with the the concepts on a general scale
i don't think you have to separate it
because what we're talking about is just
the truth so
if someone is saying something that
isn't true
our first goal should be to affirm and
and defend the truth so the reason why
they're wrong about what they're saying
is almost immaterial in my mind um
the first thing that matters the first
thing we have to establish is the truth
men are men and women are women periods
so that's our first thing
and if we want to get into the specifics
of like why are there so many people
that are confused about this in their
own for themselves
um
yeah i think i think then especially
dealing with someone on a personal level
like one-on-one
to to understand where this is coming
from is important but we also have to
realize that that gender dysphoria
people who are
you know for reasons that are almost
unexplainable really actually confused
about this
that's a that's a such a small minority
such a small sliver and all you have to
do is look back you know
a hundred years ago
how many people
were confused about
their gender like how many how many men
were going around who really thought
that they were women i'm sure there were
some like very very small numbers and
they were mentally ill it's a mental
illness and if we were still a sane
society we would treat that with
therapy counseling it's what you do for
mentally ill people you treat their
minds to the best
of your ability um
this
astronomical rise though in transgender
identification
that's obviously not
uh
just mental illness it's not something
people are born with there's something
happening
in the culture clearly
because
because in the film like the first half
an hour was really funny i was sitting
there with the lads and we were you know
we were laughing we were going like this
not bull saying this i wasn't laughing i
saw the trouble coming yeah but i was
laughing because i think you
you exposed these elements of it and it
was comically humorous but then
what was terrifying is when we saw the
medical professionals the doctors
affirming this did you expect that
because i certainly didn't
yeah i think well that's something i was
a little bit worried about actually with
the film before it came out is that we
knew we were gonna have this tonal shift
and i don't know is it too abrupt
because it's kind of weird and it is
abrupt and weird but at the same time i
think it's also necessary that like on
the surface level
this is absurd and so we laugh
at absurdity which is an appropriate
response
but then you go a little bit under the
surface you see there's some really
sinister stuff going on and that's when
you get into the
doctors who are
um
encouraging
you know who are sort of spreading this
plague and doing it in a really
intentional way
and and doctors i think certainly know
better and you know we talked to one a
pediatrician in the film uh forcier who
prescribes these drugs chemical
castration drugs to children
and um
what what was so revolting about that
aside from just you know the obvious
is that when i talked to her like she
had no
defense of the practice at all she was
not able to even begin
to defend this and yet she's doing it
and so that makes you think well if she
can't defend it then she must know that
this is wrong that's just my
you know that that that's my
interpretation
is that a lot of these people know what
they're doing is wrong and yet they do
it anyway
why would they do it anyway well
one big thing is money there's there's a
huge financial incentive we get into
that a little bit in the film but
you have to keep in mind there's
billions of dollars not for one
individual but like for these industries
there's billions of dollars at stake
and you think about you know you've got
a six-year-old kid who's says that a
six-year-old boy says he's confused
about his gender
and if you were to just say to the
six-year-old boy oh no you're a boy
and help him to accept himself for who
he is then that's great that's the right
thing to do but there's no money in that
right
if on the other hand you encourage him
[Music]
to go delve even deeper into that
confusion then that boy is worth
thousands if not millions of dollars
to
big pharma therapists doctors down the
line so i think there's a real
financial incentive
and you know we've interviewed a ton of
people about this trans people who don't
agree with some elements of this
ideology uh other people gender critical
feminist etc
and yet i was still shocked by the
second half of the movie were you
shocked by what you found in particular
with doctors and and professors i was uh
yeah that's the thing even when you
encounter something that you already
knew about intellectually it's still
shocking just to encounter it exactly to
i knew that so-called sex change or what
they call gender affirmation surgeries
now which is if a euphemism ever heard
one but uh i knew that that was
happening and yet to sit across from
someone who does this and hear that
explain it it's still shocking just to
encounter it and i was also shocked
there were some things i learned like i
before getting into the film making the
film and researching it before we filmed
it
i i did not realize
how young the kids are when they start
them on
the actual medical transition part of it
how young are they matt
well i mean as young as uh as young as
10 11 years old when they start them on
the on the hormones and you get into
puberty blockers the surgery especially
i i
year and a half ago
i didn't realize that they were actually
that they really were mutilating kids i
thought that
you know this is something that starts
at the age of 18. but no i mean they
chop the breasts off of uh
13 and 14 year old girls even younger
sometimes
i didn't i didn't realize that and it's
um i think a lot of people don't don't
realize that that's happening
and uh
hopefully now they do
well
one thing i wanted to ask you about is i
think you made a movie that whatever
people think about you or your where
you're coming at it from is valuable
that's what i believe genuinely
however the
temporary alliance between
gender-critical feminists and right-wing
conservatives like you uh was always
going to be temporary and it now seems
to be falling apart uh you know you had
a
spat on twitter with jk rowling
and others uh what do you make of the
backlash uh against the movie and
against you from that side of the of the
debate
yeah i think it's so it was an alliance
that lasted about 45 seconds it would
seem
uh which i guess was predictable i you
know to me i i it's on i find it
unfortunate it's not it's not what i
wanted i mean i
i've said from the very beginning even
before the movie came out that
uh which is one of the reasons why i've
very vocally been supportive of jk
rowling and said many times that i
really respect the way that she stood up
against the mob
um at great personal cost and
and stan she stands to gain nothing
personally from it and yet she has i i
respected that i still do
um and even if you have a billion
dollars in the bank it still takes guts
to do it and so she does it
so that's my that's my view i have a lot
of respect for anyone who stands up
against these people and stands for
truth and if you're willing to do that
on this subject which is so so important
and i think in so many ways like it this
is a civilizational crisis we're dealing
with
and so i if if you're on the right side
of this then i can join forces with you
for this fight
and then we can get back to you know
tearing each other apart after after
we're done with this that's that's how i
look at it
um and i think when the movie first came
out there was it seemed to me anyway
among some of these gender critical
feminists there was like this internal
fight among them about what do we do do
we do do we link arms with this guy or
what and
maybe for a brief moment in time it's it
seemed like maybe they would but then
ultimately i think they just decided
they they can't do it i think that um
one of the criticisms they made matt was
that you didn't include any of them in
them
yeah and that's honestly it's just not
it's it's nonsense first of all there
aren't in the movie right right
a couple things
even if it was true that i just decided
i'm going to exclude them well who cares
is this about you or i mean is this
about what do you care about here do you
care about the issue or do you care
about yourselves like it would never if
if a feminist if jk rowling did this
documentary
it wouldn't even occur to me to say well
why wasn't i in it
it just seems like such a petty arrogant
complaint who cares so who said i should
be in it you made the film you made it
the way you wanted to make it it's
important that you did it well and
that's what matters so i would champion
the film for that reason so i find that
the complaint to begin with ridiculous
it's also just not true we actually did
reach out to
um
a number of the so-called gender
critical feminists maybe not as many as
they wish we had i also i'm not i don't
live in the uk i'm not plugged in with
feminist circles so there are there are
some of these women that reached out to
me since the movie came out and said why
don't you contact me i didn't know you
existed before you just reached out to
me i'm sorry uh but uh we did reach out
to a number of do you mind if fast code
just
i
i've decided not to
for their own sake i'm not i don't want
to i don't want to throw anybody under
the bus because i don't the the truth is
for some of these names and there are
some big names okay
um i don't really know why they turned
us down so i think if i name them and
then oh so they turned you down
yeah it just didn't work out and so but
but if i name them and it sounds like
i'm claiming that they refused to
because they don't want to work with me
or they were scared i don't know if
that's true maybe it just was a
scheduling problem
all i can say is that for a fact we did
reach out and the women that we reached
out to know who they are okay
and the other criticism that was made uh
was that you
you don't act i mean i've heard some
people say this it's not my opinion but
it's an opinion that some feminists hold
it actually you don't care particularly
about women's rights this isn't where
you're coming at it from
you're just someone who's using this
issue to advance your evil conservative
agenda
uh what do you make of that i guess
that's true if my evil conservative
agenda is just to preserve truth and and
reality like that's that's what i care
about
i make no bones about the fact that
i see some of these issues as i care
about some of these issues because
they're a battleground
for the overall war for truth so um
women's sports for example
do i care deeply about women's sports
itself do i wake up every day saying
i'm really concerned about women's
women's sports no i don't watch women's
sports i don't care about it
you know in in general
but
it has become a battleground for the war
for truth so um when i'm being told that
a man should be able to compete against
women and be accepted as a woman
i'm saying no i don't accept that that's
insane
but what motivates me is not my
unabiding love for women's sports in
particular it's just my it's my love for
truth
and justice and fairness it's also not
fair like even if i don't watch women
swimming
it's really not fair to these women who
are having their opportunities stolen
from them
you've used the word civilizational
crisis to describe what we're talking
about now there'll be people watching
going come on this is still a relatively
minor thing it's not affecting a huge
wave of the population what does it
matter if you put your pronouns in your
in your email etc why is it a
civilizational crisis matt
well i think there are a few reasons and
the first i go back to the issue of
truth like true truth matters for its
own sake
and um
a civilization that
fundamentally
denies the most basic
truth the most basic realities of human
existence
cannot survive and i say that because
it's never happened before i mean i
can't think of a civilization that's
been able to pull that off it just said
we're going to swear off
we're going to pretend we live in a
different universe and continue on you
just you can't thrive as a civilization
that way
um
so that's the ground level
issue
but then also i mean we're
you look at what we're doing to children
children are being mutilated and
sterilized on a mass scale
well we talked before about the way that
the transgender identification has risen
in recent years and to just say that
it's risen i think understates the case
we're talking about exponential i mean
we're talking about for the youngest
generation they're the transgender
identification the youngest generation
is like 20 times
what it was for my parents
um
that's another reason why it's a
civilizational crisis this exponential
growth of this
identity crisis this confusion and
there's no sign that it's going to stop
i mean you don't have 20 you don't have
20 times
growth like that and then in the next
generation it just goes away
um
in fact we see it's like it's there's
this for lgbt identification in general
there's been a doubling
of lgbt identification generation over
generation doubling dating back to like
my grandparents generation
and then trans in particular
astronomical rise there
so i think that what we're seeing is
that entire generations of kids being
lost
to
this
confusion which leads ultimately to
despair what they tell us about
the trans suicide rate is true that you
know the suicide rate
is so much higher for for people who
identify as trans than it is for anyone
else
but they're lying when they say that the
way to solve the suicide rate is to
affirm the transit identification that's
that's not what the data tells us the
data tells us that no matter how firm
they are
get the surgeries get all that um
suicide rate is still high in fact
they're they're more suicidal after
surgery than before
so
what that tells us is that this leads to
despair ultimately matt do you think
that this is a symptom of something that
is deeply wrong within western society
and western culture that it's merely a
symptom there's something actually far
deeper and far darker going on there
uh i think absolutely and that's one
carl truman will tell you a lot more
about that i'll speak more eloquently
about it than i will but uh i that
that's one thing that i notice in in
these interviews is that um
so many of the interviews devolved
pretty quickly
into
[Music]
uh well what what is truth a college
professor is a fam infamous example now
that i talked to college professor
turned into this but really every single
interview i had especially even with
people on the street eventually turned
into this like punch of pontius pilate
what is truth is there a truth whose
truth are we talking about
um
and what that tells me is that the
deeper thing going on is is
uh relativism you know that's that's
people are raised in our society to
believe that we all have our own truth
truth is whatever you say it is whatever
you feel
is true you know
and um
like i remember being raised when even
when i was a kid hearing this kind of
thing all the time
and uh so i think that's what's
happening underneath all this really
this is it is a war against truth and
it's uh what lies underneath all of it
is just is relativism it's the rejection
of
of objective truth entirely and how much
do you think of this is caused by
technology one of the things that i
often think about is we now have the
technology to do some of these surgeries
in a way that we didn't have before and
obviously we now have technology to
propagate the ideology in a way that we
didn't have before and those things
coming together seems to me like two
very powerful things
that from my perspective of perhaps an
even better explanatory
uh option than
uh you know ideologues driving it like
the ideology was there and then the
technology came along to fuel it or is
it more maliciously intended you know
making money off it or whatever what's
your take uh i think i think it's all of
the above but
um you can it's been possible to
overstate the effects of technology now
you're right that
the technology
for the actual surgeries has advanced
quite a bit but it's still
a barbaric frankenstein stuff they're
doing and it always will be i mean when
you're when you're trying to construct
false genitalia there's there's doesn't
matter how advanced the the medicine is
it's always going to be you're always
it's always what you're doing you're
constructing false genitalia which is
always going to be barbaric
um
but the propagation i think is the big
thing and uh
here's what happens i think kids
they go to school
most most kids do
uh like public schools and they spend
five days a week right six seven hours a
day nine months a year for 12 or 13
years
and they're marinating in in this
pure culture where where gender ideology
now has just totally taken over
and then
that's bad enough
but then they leave school
but they don't leave the pure culture
behind because they carry it around with
them they have it in their pocket they
have on their phone so it just becomes
this kind of like fog that they never
escape this choking fog they can never
get away from
um
and the uh
the
drive and compulsion when you're a kid
to try to to try to fit in is
overwhelming and we all remember it as
kids
for a lot of adults it's still
overwhelming but especially when you're
a kid
and that's even more the case
when they are
when they can never escape their peers
and so like
you know
they're already driven to be to be
accepted by their peers but when you're
around your peers all the time even at
home you're still with them
then if you're not accepted by them then
it becomes a real crisis that's one of
the reasons why the suicide rate among
kids tragically is
so much higher than it ever was
um
and so i think that's what what drives a
lot of these ideas it just catches on
it's like the cool popular thing now
to be not necessarily to be you know to
be trans is cool and popular but the
main thing for kids is to you don't be
cis right to be anything pick something
else gender non-conforming non-binary
zizer pronouns whatever it is
uh furry like just pick something that
isn't
plain old ordinary
regular you know
um and now that's caught on there's just
no no stopping it which is why like
you know if you have to send your kid to
public school i'd recommend don't do it
but if you have to you have to
um
but there's no excuse i think to give
an adolescent kid a phone with full
internet access so they can just use all
day up in their room who knows what
they're looking at it's just it's
crazy i think yeah it is a recipe for
disaster matt we've seen
you know a huge amount of growth with
young girls and pubescent girls wanting
to transition now there's been a lot of
theories but being put about a lot of it
people are saying you know they're
autistic girls who who may feel that way
or they're girls who for whatever reason
feel desperately uncomfortable in their
bodies what do you think the reason is
behind this well i think um
first of all the the drive to be
girls in general more relational you
know they have more friends they
care more about you know what people
what their friends think um
which which often could be a a very good
thing about about about uh
you know kind of the that feminine
tendency but but at the same time it can
also lead to
you know um wanting even more to be
accepted by their peers but i think even
deeper than that
a lot of this stuff kicks in around
puberty right
and when you're going through puberty
whether you're a boy or girl your body
is changing in ways that are
confusing
and i think that's especially the case
for girls
and um the changes that girls go through
during puberty are even more drastic and
can be more sort of unsettling for the
girl
and so i think
especially at
puberty feeling sort of not at home in
your own body feeling like your body is
revolting against you and doing things
that you
don't want
it's normal to feel that way even more
normal for girls given what they
experience
the difference is that when we were all
kids you went through puberty and you
had that kind of awkward phase and it
was a phase and all the adults in your
life said it's just a phase you'll get
over it you'll be fine this is you know
all these changes are good and you'll
grow into yourself and grow into your
body and all that kind of stuff
um
but now
the adults are going around to the kid
the kids and telling them oh well if you
feel
like you're not at home in your body
then that's
because you're nice because you actually
should have a different body and here's
the other great thing they say to the
girls especially you just take a pill
and all these changes you don't want you
don't have to go through it
you know puberty is actually something
that you have to consent to like the
biology and your body doesn't have a
right to do this on its own you have to
consent to it
and you could just here's a little
magical button you can press and stop
all this and by the way here's some
testosterone you can take that reduces
your anxiety which is very natural in
that period matt we could talk to you
for a lot longer but you're a busy guy
we promised to let you go after half an
hour so wrapping up i'll ask you the
question that we always ask all of our
guests and it doesn't have to be related
to the movie or anything we've talked
about today which is what do you think
is the one thing we're not talking about
as a society that we really should be
uh
i mean there's so many things on this on
this particular topic but uh i'll
i'll say one that's that's related to it
that's just on my mind because of
something happened last week and it's
just an issue it's always been important
to me
uh we you know i think we need to talk
about
um
the pharmaceutical industry
in general
and and uh as it relates to mental
health there was this
this study that was that just came out
last week about antidepressants
um
revealing that
you know
these antidepressants have been
prescribed
um on a theory of depression that was
just
a myth and
the
pharmaceutical industry
has profited billions of dollars giving
people these drugs
that it would seem aren't doing anything
for them really
um
and that's a whole topic there you know
when we talk about depression mental
illness the way that we treat it the way
that we think about it
uh i think we need to go back and
reanalyze a lot of that on a real kind
of fundamental level
matt it has been an absolute pleasure if
people want to watch a movie where can
they do that
well you can go to whatiswoman.com
and or just go to dailywire.com become a
member subscribe and uh watch the movie
and tell all your friends about it all
right well thanks for giving us your
time and thank you for watching and
listening we'll see you very soon with
another brilliant episode like this one
or raw show all of them go out at 7 pm
uk time and for those of you who like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys hey constantin do you love
trigonometry of course incredible
interviews hilarious live streams
hard-hitting satire plus my handsome
jawline whatever takes away from your
hairline but if you do love trigonometry
and you want to support us there's only
one place to do that and that's on
locals yes locals is a brilliant
platform that has been incredibly
supportive to our show and other
problematic creators the great thing
about locals is that it's a community
for people who love trigonometry that's
right it's a place for you to hang out
with like-minded people share thoughts
memes and discuss the show you can enjoy
it for free but it also gives you the
option of supporting us for as little as
seven dollars a month and if you want to
give more you can we have incredible
rewards for our higher tier supporters
as well we've got everything from mugs
monthly group calls and one on two chats
with me and kcat get in join our
community by hitting the link in the
description and the pin comment below
see you there guys